each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
right well good morning everyone I'd
like you to help me welcome Hendler
tough and I known from Aalto University
and she completed her MSC in audio and
acoustics technology in 2012 and she's
currently a PhD student in the virtual
acoustics team where she works on the
measurement and analysis of concert
halls so we're not further ado you have
a floor all right thanks mark well first
of all good morning everyone and thanks
for having me here
yeah my name is Hannah and I'm going to
talk a bit about my research group at
the Alta University and then I'm going
to talk a bit about perceptual
evaluation of concert halls and then I'm
going to talk a bit about my PhD topic
which is actually the city perfect in
concert halls but before I start I'm
just going to explain a bit Who I am I
have a couple of passions one of my
passions is music I played the Finnish
string instrument come Talan
and that's actually what drove me to
into acoustics in the first place
so my other passion is science or
physics and I wanted to find a way to
combine these two so I did my master
thesis on the simulation of this
instrument and now I continue with my
PhD and contact hole acoustics and the
third passion I have is disseminating
information so I'm also a teacher at the
alder University and I'm the Secretary
General for the acoustical Society of
Finland among other things and I also
organize a lot of gatherings where
students can meet representatives from
the acoustics industry in Finland so
very briefly on Aalto University it was
established in 2010 when three
universities with long history designed
to join forces and to create a
university that would have technology
economics and
together and it's located right next to
Helsinki the capital Finland in Espoo
and the student environment is about
twenty thousand twenty two thousand
students and acoustic related research
is actually done in two at two
departments at the university due to
historical reasons but there are six
professors altogether and around forty
people working on acoustic related
issues and I myself I represent now the
department of computer science where we
have the virtual acoustics team which
consists of two professors we have a
couple of postdocs and seven PhD
students and if you master student and
our main goal is try to understand how
the quality of sound is modified by room
acoustics we have done concert halls
auditoriums home theater studios cars
also recently and we would like to find
out links between architecture and
perception of sound and possibly new
metrics to measure acoustic qualities of
concert hall for example we all know
that they are these ISO standards for
evaluating the concert hall sound but
from perceptual studies more recent ones
we have found out that they don't
actually very well correlate the
objective parameters with the perception
and I'll be talking about that a bit
later and the third goal of the team is
actually developing room acoustics
modeling methods mainly finite
difference time domain methods and we
used in both rooms and also more
recently now for a tour TF modeling so
the two professors the first professor
is a my professor w lo keem and he has a
slightly bigger team we have two
postdocs working on measurement and
analysis of concert halls and more in
general microphone arrays and also the
perception of knowledge especially
nonlinear aspects in the in the concert
hall acoustics and then also
the three first PC students we kind of
work on the early reflections of of the
concert hall trying to understand the
personal relevance of those and then we
have one PhD students actually working
more on audio amended reality and
navigation applications and we also have
two master students working on different
things for example we're trying to find
out if we could use heat cameras in
concert halls to try to see how people
how strongly people feel about music for
example in certain spaces then the
second team mostly focusing on room
acoustic modeling slightly more smaller
but one of the interesting things that
the team recently released is a open
source GPU spaced find a different side
to main solver which works especially
for small rooms so if you're interested
in that I highly recommend checking that
out it's available in github right so
that's the team and the research done in
the virtual acoustics team more or less
and now I'm gonna move into in a bit
more detail what my group is doing and
also where my research is related into
so perceptual evaluation of concert hall
acoustics in a concert in a symphony
concert we have we can have up to 100
musicians in the stage and pearl 2000 a
bit less than 2000 listeners and of
course when when we want to build a new
Hall we want to build this other people
love to come and listen music and there
we have like I said we have all these
objective parameters that we can use
while we're designing the hall but they
don't always correspond to the
perception of the concert hall so
already like started by Baron again
around fifty years ago he started
classifying the concert hall based on
questionnaires this work was also
continued by Baron in the 90s with
British concert halls
the problem with in-situ questionnaires
for example is that you can only compare
one concert at a time and one and one
Hall but we all know that the auditory
memory is a bit shady at times so it
might be if you evaluate a different
contact the next day you might not
actually be able to compare them very
well of course there's the question of
interpretation of different questions
how it's very important to how you
design that the questionnaire for the
for the listener so our idea is that
actually it might be very nice to hop in
real time from one hole to another have
the same work astre play all the time so
there there wouldn't be different
members playing on different days have
the same music and have the same playing
style timing and level I mean often
times orchestras they practice in a
certain hall and they learn the
acoustics of the hall and then they
adjust their playing according to that
as well so we would like to have this
kind of standardized way of listening to
the concert halls so we have roughly two
options we have to provide a device for
teleportation for people to to hop on
and off between different concerts or we
can try to simulate a symphony orchestra
and then bring that to a listening room
and have people listen to that so this
is a this is our approach and for that
our main research tools that we use are
the spatial impress responses that we
have recently been recording all over
Europe without a loudspeaker Orchestra
here you can see the the orchestra on
stage in one of the halls and we use a
grass probe fix my six problem
microphone to record the spatial impulse
responses
then of course we have we need some
musical instruments for our Orchestra so
we have any quick recordings of 14
musical instruments and we have a
listening room in our lab that has 24
generals in in 3d with the kind of
self-made absorption all over the the
room so if I talk a bit about the tools
here I can show you a small video about
the the loudspeaker Orchestra and how
the measurement setup looks like so we
went around in Europe in on a concert
tour with the loudspeaker Orchestra and
this is the setup in vienna music for
i'm so we have 32 loudspeakers set on
the stage in the positions that would
simulate the symphony orchestra and then
we have also manipulated a bit tired
activities of the loudspeakers by
combining two loads because some of them
are on the floor so that they would
respond to better respond to the
directivity of the instruments the
loudspeaker orchestra yeah it needs the
musical instruments as well so what we
did is we took 14 professional musicians
one by one in an anechoic room they had
the conductor video for temple of
playing and then they had the sheet here
of course and they could listen to a
piano track on open headphones while
they were playing so they were more or
less in tune and of course we took only
one instrument per instrument section so
we had to also create some methods for
creating section sound for a section
chant for a music the string instrument
so for example we did some live tracking
of bowing motions of of violin players
in an orchestra
and of course you can manipulate it a
bit by by also by changing the tuning of
the of the violin a little bit so you
get the sensation of different kinds of
musical instruments and the last tools
that we we need our course for analysis
and visualization and here is one
example of a plot that we frequently use
in our work so we basically sum all the
loudspeakers on the stage so that we can
kind of get how the Symphony Orchestra
would would be like at the receiver
position so this is the impulse response
the time frequency development of the
impulse response in the room so we take
a rectangular window of the impulse
response at a certain time window and
then we take the frequency response of
that so here we start at 20 milliseconds
after the direct sound and then we
increase in action this is the 30
millisecond yeah curve after the
direction then we had increase the time
window button with 10 milliseconds at a
time well and then the red curve you see
here is the the frequency response of
the fool impulse response man so we can
quite nicely see the development of the
frequency response over time here in a
hall and then that helps us in the
analysis and I will show a bit later
some examples of that and the second
tool that we use often well we need to
of course since we're recording with a 6
from microphone we want to know also the
the spatial temporal response of our of
a room so we use for that we use our own
method which is called spatial
decomposition method where you basically
just estimate the direction of arrival
for each sample in in an impulse
response
yeah so here's one example of a single
source at a stage a single loudspeaker
and then again we have the different
time windows for the impulse response so
you can quite nicely see how the spatial
temporal input and frequency response is
developing here and you can quite nicely
see where some individual reflections
are coming from well this is of course
the direct sound and then here you have
some reflection of the of the wall or
actually it's probably oh yeah it's
probably off the back wall there's some
kind of a construction in this concert
hall that gives you this reflection
right so these are the analysis tools
but then of course when we do perceptual
evaluation we also need a tools for to
to create a little listening test
and one of the ways to to do track
comparisons between Roman cousteau
qualities actually taken from the wood
food industry so you can you can listen
to concert halls a bit like your tasting
wines so you can do this kind of vocally
elicitation which I will explain in a
bit there's a very nice overview article
off of this in the physics today if you
have time if you don't have time for
anything else have a bit of time and
read this it's very informative and very
nicely written yeah so tasting music
like wine you can use one of the
techniques used in wine tasting and
another food tasting in consumer product
evaluation is called individual cap rate
profiling and this is also what we used
for the concert halls and it's very nice
for the Assessors because you can you
can create your own attributes for
listening you don't have complicated
questionnaires or instructions of what
to do you can just listen and decide
where you
here differences so first you develop
you listen and you develop your own
attribute let's say I think this one is
loud this one sounds muddly this one
sounds like it had a lot of
reverberation or this one sounds like
it's very distant for example so you can
develop these attributes and then in the
second phase you take these attributes
and you take the concert halls then you
compare the concert halls with your own
attributes so what we did for example is
that we had a simple AP test with
different concert halls and different
positions and we asked okay which one of
the samples has more of the muddiness
that you described for example and from
there on we can do an analysis and and
some clustering which I will show in a
bit but of course this approach assumes
that there's some kind of common
characteristics in the halls that are
perceived in the same way or in a
similar manner by the Assessors but they
might describe with different words so
this is where the grouping and the
clustering and different kinds of
classes for the attributes come in so
here's an example of how we created this
the workflow for the listening test
using the IVP first this is simple first
of all it's altogether eight hours of
listening which is kind of tough for the
listener so dizzy written in chunks so
there's the first there is a preference
test just a simple reference test to get
to know the your samples and then of
course we screened the people for all
geometry and then in the second phase
you create these attributes and one of
the ways to do that is to do an a/b test
where you ask the the listener or the
Assessor to find the sample that's
different and then describe the
difference
with their own words and then there
might be a lot of different attributes
that come out from different Assessors
so at some time they have to discuss
with with the examiner a bit and then
they they come out they decide on a
group of two to four attributes and then
they do the AP comparison between the
different hopes so this is just one way
of running this and yeah here I you can
see that I have two different music
samples in the Indus test that I will
actually describe now so this is a one
of our latest work it's actually now
currently in review at the also so we
did is a wine tasting test with six
concert halls in Europe three shoe box
halls and three non-supe box halls which
kind of include like a vineyard type of
hole the Berliner Philharmonie and the
Music Center in Finland and then a more
of a fan-shaped all the that
Philharmonia
in Cologne and yeah so we took three
different seating positions one in the
front one in the partner repeat to the
side and then one in the balcony where
where there wasn't the balcony then it
was just further back at the same
distance and we had two different
musical samples so except from Bruckner
with a lot of horns a lot of brass
instrument in general very powerful and
then as an exhale except from
Beethoven's seventh symphony which had
more like just strings and it was played
in piano so that we could fish out the
differences between the concert hall the
weather and the music does make a
difference whether you like the
acoustics or not
and we took 28 subject professional
musicians amateur musicians and active
country callers mmm and like I said
before it's six holes that amounts to 15
pairs and because we had three seats in
each hole and we wanted to also compare
all of them together so we had 45 pairs
altogether for the listeners and here
you can see pictures of the of the
positions that we we chose and one thing
to notice here is of course we when we
did them both response measurements the
rooms were unoccupied so in some cases
this way altered the properties of the
concert hall compared to the one that
when it's completely occupied so this we
know just in particular in the music
Ferren in vienna that because the seats
are hardwood the reparation time was a
lot longer than what it is actually when
it's when the hall is fully seated so
that may have affected the results but
otherwise you see that the the seats
have some perfect material so they try
to kind of also imitate the absorption
of humans in a way so yeah the front
stalls position then one and the part
Arabic to the side you can also actually
see it's quite interesting how the these
these are these have exactly the same
physical distance but also visually they
they look completely different and then
the one at the balcony
right so of course that it doesn't look
like exactly like our a contact whole
are listening room but nevertheless we
have covered the lots because with the
curtains so there are no visual clues
choose and you use the touch screen to
to maneuver the test and of course we
didn't tell the subjects exactly what
they were listening to we just explained
them the instructions and that was it
and here I have an example of how the
paired comparison looks like how the
listening test looks like and here you
can also see the sound here the sound
so you can quite seamlessly hop between
the the samples and listen and then
decide for yourself which one in this
case which one you liked
for example better right then
so which attributes did people actually
come up with and how how would we group
them up so yeah we did this kind of
classification with the help of maximum
likelihood so of course when we asked
people which one you like better or
which one has more of that we get just
the binary data and for this with you we
can get scale values out and then we can
do a classification based on maximum
likelihood and the groups that showed up
in both samples more or less we're
loudness or our base so how how much
sound there is how how best it sounds
reverberant so the subjective impression
of reverberation or how wide the sound
is and then clarity so how well you can
hear the different instruments for
example proximity which is how intimate
how close the sound is for you or
alternatively on the other side how
distant it is and then finally
brightness so how how brilliant the
sound is for you and you can see that
the groups or the terms differ a bit
between the samples but this is of
course completely dependent on the music
style but these groups they are very
similar to groups that have been found
in previous studies as well so we could
say that we could argue that concert
hall acoustics can be described with
these five more or less five groups and
we also found some correlations between
the groups and the objective parameters
that you can see her see on the top so
mostly these parameters or these these
attributes can be explained by some part
of the loudness or the strength
parameter G at different frequencies and
also somewhat the the lateral energy
that you have within the in the room and
clarity can someone be explained by the
ratio between the early and the late
sound to see the c80 at certain
frequencies but what is interesting that
there is no this has also been found
previously that there's no clear
objective parameter at the moment that
would describe what proximity actually
what does it consist of in the objective
sense
yeah just so that we did some years back
we also did a similar kind of listening
test with a bit different mythology for
finished and finished concert halls and
we ended up with very similar groups
with clarity reverence loudness
messiness and proximity so very similar
terms in a way but this was done with
here article clustering so the method
was a bit different okay and then so we
found these attributes but how about
preference like which hole did people
actually you know like what what has
them which hole has the best acoustics
if we look at all the data together of
all these people we find that people
most likely prefer the Berlin concert
house which is a kind of standard
shoebox house with quite a lot of bass
and interestingly this preferences can
be explained mostly or it's correlated
mostly with the attribute of proximity
which we cannot really explain in the
objective terms yet so this is something
that we will definitely look into in the
future what is it actually that
acoustically defines proximity however
because we have untrained subjects and
we also know but the preference might
not be so straightforward we actually
did the also a kind of a latent class
segmentation so a method of trying to
find out whether there are different
groups within the data and we did find
three preference groups and the first
one is about 23% of the data and we
couldn't find these these people or
these this preference group they like
the the Berlin concert has the most but
we couldn't find any correlation between
an attribute group so it's a kind of a
group that we cannot really explain that
well but the second group which is more
interesting is that they seem to you see
here on the on the left you have all the
shoe box holes so they seem to prefer
the the shoe box holds over the non shoe
box holes and for this we found
significant correlation with the
attributes of loudness with
reverberation and proximity so this
group tends to like loud wide enveloping
reverberant sound that feels like it's
closed and then the third group here we
can see that this group clearly prefers
the colon philharmonie but also the
other non shoebox halls and for this we
found that there's significant
correlation between clarity and
definition so how well you can distinct
with the different elements on the stage
and we have found significant negative
correlation and with reverence loudness
and width so these guys like a clear
clear sound
so in essence we have two preferences we
have the people who like the shoeboxes
which is loud and Reverend and the nonce
epoxy which is kind of some people
Electrical totally honest sound so the
shoebox you have allowed in white sound
with with a lot of envelop of
reverberation and you also have more
bass and more high frequencies which
somehow also related to the in the mid
in the messy of the sound and it feels
like you're inside the music somehow a
lot of people describe it in that way
but then the the people who prefer the
non shoeboxes they they feel like
they're looking at the music the sound
is is clear and defined and no less
reverent and there's a less space and
less high frequencies so the sound is
also a bit more distant and this is what
we gathered from also from the
attributes but also from the acoustics
point of view the super halls have a lot
more lateral reflections which
contribute to the the Louden and white
sound and I will actually talk about
that a bit more now because I'm moving
into my research topic so this is a kind
of the the main thing that we do in a
way with this wine tasting but I'm
looking at a small subset of phenomena
in the concert hall acoustics which is
the CT perfect and it's actually very
much related to these these two
different differences in between the
shoebox and the non shoebox holes so the
city perfect how does it manifest itself
in the frequency response or in the
concert hall first of all you see that
there this is the again the time
frequency plot of
different concert halls a shoebox Hall
the Berlin concert house and a buy a
vineyard hole the Berlin Philharmonic
and here you can see the the frequency
response at 20 milliseconds after the
direct sound and this is the frequency
response of the full impulse response
and here you can see the time frequency
development of both of these holes so if
we look at the 20 millisecond after the
direct sound we notice that there is a
dip in the frequency response mostly at
low to mid frequencies so in a average
shoebox Hall the dip looks a bit like
this it's it's quite steep and it's wide
so it means that it actually takes away
a lot of the debates and especially mid
frequencies in the direct sound and in
the non shoebox holes it typically looks
like this it's a very narrow deep and
quite steep but it just is usually at a
lower frequency than in the shoebox hole
so the main attenuation frequency and
then also the with these are this is how
it manifests itself but then we see that
there is also something which which
helps us to correct the substrate
correct the CT perfect so we see that at
the end the final response there is no
longer this dip but here it is but here
it isn't at least so yeah so here this
is the 20 millisecond and then this is
every 10 10 milliseconds until 200
milliseconds and then the phone which is
around 2 seconds yeah so we see that
there's some kind of an increase in the
energy at the low frequencies and
typically it's a lot higher in the
shoebox holes and in the non shoebox
holes in the
nann toolbox hoes there tends to be this
this dip that kind of stays in the full
response as well and in a way you can if
you think about what I said about the
brutally honest sound for the nun
shoebox holes you can see it here that
already in the 20 millisecond the
frequency response kind of has its shape
already and it just then the energies of
keep on increasing but the shape stays
the same so the frequency content is
already there in the direct sound in a
way but with the non shoebox holes you
see that the the 20 millisecond the
shape of the 20 millisecond frequency
response is actually quite much
different from the final one so it means
that some frequency content gets add up
over time so I know you know in a way
the sound is more lively in that sense
as well and so this is this is a all
started off by the CT perfect and where
does it actually come from this tip at
the 20 millisecond so it has to be
something that's almost immediate to the
direct the direct sound and what it is
actually is that it's the the direct
sound it's a destructive interference
between the direct sound and the
reflection that comes from the from the
the sound that bends between the seeds
so it's essentially a destructive
interference between the signal and it's
delayed copy and this this happens when
the sound from the source travels at a
very low angle to the to the seed to the
level formed by the seed tops and then
it will Bend between the seeds and then
reflect off the floor and meet the
direct sound of the receiver positioned
here you can see an example that here's
a frequency response of of a
of the dirac sounder is actually the 20
millisecond after the direct sound this
is in the in the stalls and here you
have one in the front seat of the
balcony where you don't see the this
tape so it definitely has to do with the
with the seat actually because we're
dealing with such low frequencies here
that the audience doesn't have a big an
effect on the main attenuation at around
100 to 200 Hertz no no this yeah yeah in
this case it doesn't it doesn't matter
right so the main attenuation actually
depends on the effective seat height so
when we have the direct sound and the
first reflection of the the from the
between the seats this distance
difference between the direct sound and
the reflection it should be half half a
wavelength longer than the direct sound
so the the seat height should correspond
to 1/4 of the of the attenuation
frequency and then at higher frequencies
we also because the distance difference
is not so long we also get this like
reflections from the seat tops and this
causes some destruction in the in the
higher frequencies like at 1 kilohertz
or something like this and there are
different seat designs in the in the
concert hall and of course this will
then change you can then change the main
attenuation frequency depending on your
seat design so there's a an open seat
like the ones you're sitting on now so
there's some air between the seats so
actually then the
reflect from the botton of the feedback
as well as from the seafloor then there
are these kind of cloth seats where the
seat back extends all the way up to the
floor then you just get reflections like
this between the seats and then in some
cases where you have a raked floor the
the raking will block the the seat back
a bit and you will have a reflection
from here so the main attenuation
frequency will depend on the seat height
well I can show that actually now here
so the cloth seat what will happen is
that it will cause this kind of a narrow
dip because when you look at this is the
closed seat this is an example of the
closed reflection the distance the the
part that the sound can travel are more
or less of the same length like and
imagine that this actually has to be a
raked floor I don't have a picture of
that right now
but the rake floor that has a reflection
like that and then the reflected sound
actually it's directed more upwards so
it doesn't it doesn't go through this
the second Bend thing so to say so what
you end up having is a lot of paths for
the sound destructive sound that are the
same length so you end up having a very
narrow dip like that whereas when you
have an open seat and especially with a
flat floor like most of the shoe box
holes are you get a lot of different
path lengths and then it means that the
destructive interference is over also
spread over different frequencies but
yes to answer to your question which one
is better like to realize this is this
better than this I mean we cannot what
can we actually erase the whole effect
this is a what I'm trying to also
explore a bit oh yeah
let's say so the answer to your question
there has been 12 times when since the
effect was discovered in 64 ways to try
to completely remove the effect by okay
you know you can break the floor and you
can move the frequency like I showed you
you can move the main attenuation at a
low frequency which maybe it's not that
bad you know we cannot really we're not
that sensitive at low frequencies are we
so maybe that would be a good idea or we
could since we know that it's due to a
reflection from the flow between the
seats what if we add absorbers or
resonant bits between the seats
maybe that will remove the effect
altogether okay yeah that's very nice it
works to some extent yes it will move it
to a different frequency but there's
actually evidence that perceptual
evidence that we want the CD perfect to
be there we want the direct sound to
knock some low frequencies so that they
can come in later and they will sound
more clear they will sound they will not
sound as muddy when they come a bit
later then in the direct sound so I have
here took two shoe box holes that have
this kind of wide CD perfect and two non
shoe box holes that have a more narrow
band effect and I I did the listening
test III put low-frequency instruments
which I assumed would be heavily
affected on the CT perfect I put them to
play in these controls and I invited
people to do a listening test and I
asked them this pair to be called paired
comparison test that we also saw in
previously and I asked them about the
level of bass which one has more bass
and if we look at the here you can see
the answers we see that the the two shoe
box holes they are almost always chosen
to have louder bass which you wouldn't
immediately think so
with such a heavy lack on the base on
the direct sound so actually trying to
move the the CT perfect to a lower
frequencies may not be such a good idea
after all we might actually want to have
something like this
there's also another piece of evidence
that shows is another research where you
had an echo that was order direct sound
some noise that was missing the low
frequencies it was having approximately
this kind of a shape and then another
echo you could hear that was broadband
but when you played this together
actually the echo was perceived as
heavily low passed so you could hear the
bass in the echo even though it was
broadband so this kind of suggests that
we might actually have an enhanced
perception of bass if it's missing in
the direct sound yeah yeah here
definitely so this may not also be there
what we want in fact yeah so at the very
low frequencies we yeah we don't want
this to happen
yeah yeah we can um I'm not sure what
wondered what to argue with that
question I mean yes they can there is
this whole missing fundamental thing
that for example here even if I was
missing the fundamental of the double
bass I might get it from the from the
harmonics but in this case you also have
to consider the whole acoustics of the
concert hall I mean here you just get
there's just so much more energy coming
at the later stage than here that I
guess that overrules the when you
compare them
by one and this is actually something
that has also an implication on how the
orchestra could or should play in
different kinds of concert halls so what
I'm looking into now is this kind of
asynchronous for intentional asynchrony
in playing so I have different
instrument groups I have their low
frequencies instruments which are the
double bass in the tuba then I have the
triple instruments which are the cello
mostly and then I have the sorry the
middle of course and then I have the
treble which is all the other violins
horns all that stuff so I I manipulated
there are a lot of big orchestra and I
put them to play all synchronously and
then also in asynchronous so that the
bass would play first and then the
middle and then the treble and then also
the other way around and I did an online
listening test
we'd been order samples and I asked
people with which which playing they
preferred the best and then I also took
two different concert halls so one hole
that has this that is a shoebox shoebox
Hall where the low frequencies alive a
bit later and then announced Reeboks
Hall where the the shape of the response
is already in the is the same so you
have all the frequency content in the
direct sound already so then I asked
people which they which condition they
prefer the best of course they didn't
tell them what I was asking and we found
out was that in the shoebox Hall most
people prefer the option where the bass
instrument play a bit before everything
else if they play completely
synchronously at the same time yeah you
notice that the bass actually comes in a
bit later so it might be masked more by
what is already there if they play a bit
before you can actually get a bit more
bass out of the sound
whereas in the non shoebox hole here
where the shape of the frequency
response doesn't change that much
there wasn't a significant difference
between the synchronous and the base
playing first condition of course people
didn't really like that the triple
instruments the violins played first and
then after that you get attack from the
timpani and and the double bass this is
not a natural condition per se but I
just wanted to have it as a reference
point so now I'm running more I'm
running listening tests on this and in
our lab now with the with the spatial
loudspeaker system because this was just
online and a brief like introduction to
it so there's a very nice video about I
don't know if you know a herbert von
Kahr I am the well he's already deceased
but he was the conductor for The pieman
for harmony and he in that video he when
he explains the orchestra how to play he
actually tells the basis to to enter a
bit earlier then than the rest of the
instruments so there's some kind of
anecdotal evidence that conductors are
doing this already in a way but this of
course is not linked with the concert
hall acoustic properties yeah yeah
that's what they often oftentimes do as
well and there might be also other
reasons why they play why for example
they advise the bass to play to advance
a little it might not be the seed yeah
okay I think that concludes my part of
the presentation the this seat effect is
still a very ongoing research process
we're not exactly yeah yet sure what
would be the best thing what kind of
recommendations we should give the
architects you know what kind of seeds
to build and and things but we're
working on that and yeah also working
towards more wine and other tasting
methods for concert halls so if you have
any more questions